hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign okay and
today we're gonna be talking about how
to get the loot the fastest any new
Halloween event fangs of the other world
so as always like the video if you do
enjoy subscribe a free new I cover the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes and the leaks
it's in order to catch the day with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner I never miss out on an update
don't we stay subscribe the channel and
with that let's get started with today's
video so right away like I said we're
gonna be talking about how to get the
loot the fastest and in that specific
loop of course with the Halloween event
we have to go over what exactly
constitutes as loot and that is going to
be the new ornament the battle outfit
the effect and the weapon the execution
and the mask outfit or aka illustrious
outfit does not count the execution and
the illustrious outfits are count as
unlockables meaning you must purchase
them with steal and the weapon the
effect the battle often the ornament are
lootable meaning you can get them from
games if you want to know specifically
what they are you can check this video
in the top right if you click the I and
I have the video explaining everything
about the event and what exactly those
ornaments battle off its effects and
weapons look like so you just so you
know ahead of time if you got the new
event loot so right away these these
four items are available for every game
mode including arcade as well and with
the weapons you have to make sure that
you're playing with a specific character
so if you do want a gladiator gear
you're gonna need to be playing as
gladiator the other three don't matter
it's all / it's all pretty much random
and it's just a toss up hopefully you
get the exact one that you want for the
character that you play so that's why I
made this guide because of that issue
and the best way to do it is with arcade
as usual for the recap it's essentially
the same as last year if not the same
exact quest that we got from last year
which kind of sucks I was hoping for a
little bit more diversity but it's not a
really too big of a deal
because honestly it really wasn't the
heart of a quest anyway so it's the same
thing I don't need to learn anything new
the first one is a simple one on one
with shaman who plays a lot like a level
3 shaman bot so definitely watch out for
a lot of the faints and deflects you'll
be doing the second one is a 2v1 but you
gain mad revenge and heavies knock down
very quickly so this really isn't too
bad of a fight either any character with
long arcing heavies like JJ will
definitely succeed at this so if you
have any characters like that even if
you don't want to get the weapons if you
just want to grind it for those effects
you can use them as like farm characters
for this
the third is to shamans and one can say
and this is easily the hardest one in my
opinion cuz the minions actually smack
you for a lot but if you don't want to
fight them in a three-on-one because you
do gain matter avenge but for this as
well
behind the minions on each side there is
a Ledge that you can throw them off of
just like in the regular Dominion map I
didn't need to use that last year I
definitely did but now with the new gear
and all the stuff that I've gotten with
the new characters and them decreasing
the difficulty for this stuff it wasn't
as bad so I didn't really need the
lighters anymore the very last one is
three shamans two of which are bleeding
and all of them have timers meaning you
have to kill them roughly around the
same time or they start respawning and
if you want to make sure they die
quickly
don't bother executing I'll show a clip
on screen of me trying to execute trying
to finesse you'll have a little bit of
fun with the new execution and they've
all ended up spawning back and I could
have ended it right there but I got a
little bit too cocky so if you want to
make sure they're definitely finished
don't bother executing or it's gonna be
a very tough time especially if it's a
longer execution like the new one I
really don't have many tips for this
there isn't really anything you can do
to throw them I'm pretty sure you can
throw them from the top of the area
where you are to the bottom but that
really doesn't do much damage it's more
used for giving you a little bit more
breathing room so instead of being in a
three on one or a two on one it's not
lowered so it's a little bit easier to
fight in control who's fighting you but
honestly with the heavy damage that
gladiator head and the revenge I was
constantly getting I was doing pretty
well and gladiators more of a one on one
character so if he can do that you guys
can definitely do it too with characters
like JJ T on D etc this it really isn't
that bad of an arcade quest this time
around I should of course preface that
if you're watching this like a week
later or two weeks later or whatever it
happens to be this might not actually be
the same stuff and these arcade quests
will definitely be different because
they go on a weekly basis sadly I won't
I don't actually know what those are
because at the time I'm recording this
is the exact day that the event went
live so I actually have no clue what
those are if they are the exact same as
last year's then they probably shouldn't
be too difficult either but hopefully
they're not regardless as for if you
don't have arcade there's really no
other option besides that of course you
can play any other game mode of course
you can get loot in any game mode in for
honor even including arcade but if you
want the very very best it is going to
of course be arcade so at this point I
really just been playing any game mode
that I have you know that's maybe
tickled my fancy for
I have been in situations before where
I've played multiple brawl matches just
enough to match about one Dominion game
and I've gotten the same loot like I
played one Dominion game got like three
loot and then for the brawl matches I
got like nothing then two and then one
so really I think it's based off of time
so at that point if you're not playing
arcade I would just play any game of the
year enjoying at the moment the new art
and you know but always make sure that
it's brawl AI or whatever or whatever
game mode you're playing make sure it is
AI you of course want to make it go a
little bit faster get a little bit more
than XP you know get just something at
least to do something at least while
you're grinding for all those weapon
parts and such but overall honestly it's
not too bad if you do have some
foolproof method that I have no idea
about that involves you not using Arcade
definitely let me know in the comments
below and I'll be sure to test that
theory and see and definitely let people
other people know within the comments as
well about that because it's really cool
other than that guys it's gonna be the
end of a day hopefully you guys did
enjoy maybe about this time I might be
over 50,000 subs if I'm not in that [ __ ]
but if I am I appreciate all the support
guys they got so much it's a giant
number and we're halfway to the play
button we had a whole lot of stuff
coming foreigners got season 12 right
around the corner we got some juicy info
to talk about that one that's releases
all about the new character I'm super
excited to see what this one's gonna be
about they definitely got to step up to
the plate cuz they're pretty much a
lacking at the moment let me know what
you guys think about this in the
comments below let me know what you guys
about anything this new event the new
method anything like that in the
comments below I looked under your
thoughts I was always like to be if you
do enjoy subscribe if you're new I
covered the informational side a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the patches and leaks
if only we kept it today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
and never miss out on an update that we
stay subscribe to the channel guys take
care have a great today and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]